supporters dismantle a fence and clear
road blocks near Kowloon Tom garrison
the soldiers rarely leave their barracks
they were last seen a year ago
cleaning up after typhoon man code Rob
McBride has more now from Hong Kong it
was a very quick operation the lasted
less than an hour and the soldiers
didn't have to travel far this is their
base here the sentries are standing just
off to my right here and basically they
came out that they didn't travel very
far they came up this this road here
moving bricks as they went and turned
the corner at the top along the
perimeter up there and then we were back
inside inside the camp there they
weren't wearing uniform they were in
their sports kit as so it but it could
be looked at as quite symbolic depending
on your politics and as we know there is
a lot of politics here on the one hand
it could be seen as a fairly innocuous
gesture this is just a public spirited
action by the local garrison coming out
and as you mentioned there it's not the
first time that troops have been
deployed they came out a year ago to
help clean up in country parks after a
typhoon so it has happened before but
then this is not the country parks we're
in the urban area at the middle of
Kowloon and over on this side is one of
the university campuses where we've seen
protests and there have been an angry
standoff between students from this
campus and soldiers inside here who they
were shown there pointing their lasers
at having said that we have not seen any
angry responses from protesters that the
removal of their bricks in fact if
anything they've really played it cool
they've kept a very low profile there's
been some chatter on social media saying
though it doesn't really matter we'll
just replace the bricks when we are good
and ready but there will be others in
the pan Democratic camp who will see
this you know as a further gesture as a
further symbol of more erosion of Hong
Kong's autonomy and the autonomy it's
meant to have a within China